in 2016 a team of astronomers led by
Mike Brown and Constantine beian
published a paper in the journal Nature
claiming to have discovered a ninth
planet in our solar system the planet
was thought to be a super Earth that was
orbiting the Sun at a distance of about
700 astronomical units Brown and beian
had observed a number of unusual orbits
of objects in the so-called Kyper belt
they hypothesized that these unusual
orbits were being caused by the
gravitational pull of a large unseen
Planet this is a major news story and it
was even featured on the cover of the
New York Times however in 2021 a new
study found no evidence to support the
existence of Planet 9 the original study
was retracted Planet 9 is probably still
out there and there are many experiments
looking for it including Mike Brown and
Constantine ban the Kyper belt is a
mysterious Zone not quite planets not
quite comets they might be holding the
key to the formation of our entire solar
system it sure would be great if they
were back to having nine planets in our
solar system although Pluto might still
be jealous